CBS News contributor at key O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for the
Washington Post he is in our Washington
bureau at good morning good morning guys
how are you what's the message from
these elections messages Republicans
have to figure out whether they're going
to fully embrace trumpism or totally
divorce themselves from it Ed Gillespie
the Republican candidate in Virginia was
trying to do a little bit of both and it
didn't work for him he never campaigned
alongside the president but he was
trying to use the president's messaging
in really negative campaign ads that
aired across the state they were
rejected by voters last night for
Democrats the message is that candidate
recruitment the enthusiasm they're
seeing among voters it's legit the data
now shows that they are turning out and
Democrats are getting elected up and
down the ballot whether it's governor of
Virginia governor of New Jersey
mayor of Saint Petersburg Florida
retaking full control of state
government out in Washington State it's
happening the data proves now he's ready
to talk about issues like health care
than to talk about anti Trump Trump
things it appears to be yes Charlie I
think a good example of that for
exertive E news anchor who's whose
girlfriend was killed live on television
was inspired to run by gun violence but
focused most of his campaign not on gun
control but on education on the economy
and on health care and if you look
especially at the results in Virginia
last night health care off the charts is
the number one concern Democrats have
been saying that to us for weeks that
it's going to be a motivating factor the
proof last night is that it really is
what's the message in New Jersey and
look Chris Christie's great for
television and bad for bridge traffic
but this was all about his unpopularity
the Democrat is a former goldman sachs
banker you would think that democrats
would reject that but the state of New
Jersey is just over him they want him
gone the Lieutenant Governor was just
too closely tied to him you look at
attempts to find national trends now I
think in New Jersey what it was was all
about the unpopularity of Chris Christie
all right thank you very much ed O'Keefe
always good to have you with us